(soft music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the "Addy Hour."
It's my privilege, of course,
to be able to continue
hosting these conversations.
And, today, I'm absolutely
honored to be able to host
former Congressman Patrick J. Kennedy
for a conversation about mental health,
about politics and about advocacy.
So, obviously, this is a name
that I'm sure is familiar
to all of you as listeners,
but I want to do due diligence,
and do a little bit of an introduction
for Congressman Kennedy as well.
So during his time in Congress,
Patrick J. Kennedy was the
lead author of the landmark
Mental Health Parity and
Addiction Equity Act,
also known as the Federal Parity Law,
which requires insurers to cover treatment
for mental health, and
substance use disorders,
with no more restrictively
than they would for treatment
for illnesses of the body.
As founder of the Kennedy Forum,
he now unites advocates, policymakers,
and business leaders to advance
evidence-based practices,
and policies in mental
health and addiction.
In 2017, he was appointed to
the President's Commission
on Combating Drug Addiction
and the Opioid Crisis.
He currently serves
as co-chair of the
National Action Alliance,
specifically for the Suicide
Prevention's Mental Health,
and Suicide Prevention
National Response to COVID-19.
And he serves as co-chair of
the Bipartisan Policy Center's
Behavioral Health Integration Task Force.
So someone who has been about this work
for a very long time.
I did mention to the congressman
before we got on the air
that I had the privilege of
actually hearing him speak
at an event back in
2014 here in New Haven,
a Global Health and the Arts event.
And I was struck by just his
candor in sharing his story,
and really trying to move things forward.
I will also say that on a personal note,
it's been just a joy and
an honor for me to see
the ways that he's continued
to be about this work
on so many different levels,
really addressing things like stigma,
of course, thinking about policy,
also thinking about
access to care, insurance,
but then also tying in,
and making sure that
we have an understanding of
what happens in mental illness,
and understanding the brain,
and really having the
research to move that forward.
So I'm absolutely honored, again,
to be able to welcome former
Congressman Patrick J. Kennedy
to the "Addy Hour."
- Thank you, Dr. Addy, it's
a pleasure to be with you.
And I just wanna thank you
on behalf of all my fellows
who have benefited from
professions of psychiatry,
and psychology for all you've done
to try to face the challenge
that we're facing as a nation
by dedicating your careers,
and your mission to really helping people
not only on a medical level,
but just really help them
build back some agency,
and reclaim their lives,
and no longer kind of be marginalized
because society would do
that to them ordinarily.
And so thank you so much.
You do have a spiritual
dimension to your job,
which is underappreciated
because when you're restored
to physical wellbeing,
the transformations to your family,
and community are so enormous,
but that's not often appreciated
in the work that you do.
So thank you for that.
- Of course, and thank
you for those kind words.
And in a lot of ways this podcast,
in addition to what I do
on a professional level
has been a joy
to be able to pull so many
different people together
as you've alluded to as well,
even as you talked about
the spiritual component,
and just to be able to have
different people come together
in this podcast forum,
and even in the event
that you did back in 2014,
to see researchers and
clinicians and actors,
and public advocates
all in the same space,
trying to move these things forward.
So I know we're complimenting
each other here,
but I think it's just
important to acknowledge
how important that is
in terms of really trying
to move things forward.
It's just an honor to do that.
- Gratitude is a mindset,
and an attitude I've learned
to cultivate in recovery
from addiction and mental illness.
The default mode for my brain
is to think about the negative,
to ruminate about my fears
of losing what I have,
or not getting what I want.
And part of my mental wellbeing
is to transform that thought process,
which is negative to one where,
because I'm trained through
cognitive behavioral therapy,
which is what 12-step recovery is to me
to always look every day in a humble way,
how I can be of service to someone else
that gets me outta my own
self-centered thinking.
And so I wanna say that
this is not outta some,
like, pure adulation,
or sucking up to you.
I just wanna really point
out to your listeners
that this is about
living life differently.
It saves us trying to
be open to other people.
And so I was grateful to
be invited to be on this.
- Oh, of course, of course.
And that's so well said,
and I appreciate even the
way that you've already
just start to take us on your journey,
and to show us the importance of that
as we walk through
those different aspects,
and have that different approach
and that different mindset,
all the things that we can do
with cognitive behavioral therapy,
and how important that is
for us as we're walking
through these journeys, so.
I'm already appreciative.
I knew you'd be able to
bring that level of candor and insight,
and grateful that you've already
even started to share that
in this moment.
And even to follow-up on
that as my listeners know,
I always like to start out,
and you've done this already,
just checking in,
and seeing how people are doing
in the midst of everything
that we're continuing to
experience as a society.
Obviously, there are so many
things that are going on
at this point in time,
even as we we're in the
middle of the hearings
around the January 6th situation,
all the things that we're
continuing to walk through
just as we continue to
navigate the pandemic,
as people are still getting sick,
as we're experiencing
tragic situation after tragic situation,
but then as we also have reasons for hope
in the work that we do
as you've alluded to,
and just the joy that we can have
from being in community
with one another, so.
That was a long-winded
introduction, but just to say,
I wanted to start there,
and see just how you're
doing at this point in time.
- I appreciate that.
I really feel the biology in my brain
is where I sink or swim,
because I really feel overwhelmed
throughout the week here and there,
but because of that issue of
cognitive behavioral therapy,
'cause I know that feelings aren't facts,
but in recovery I know that
I used to drink and drug over feelings,
even though they're not facts,
like, so I learn in recovery
to take a gratitude list of
all the great things in my life
because I have to do a reality check
because even if with everything,
as you said is so unhinged
around us in the world today,
and we're really off-kilter in my view,
in our culture, society, just in large,
the toxicity of our political culture,
the obviously existential
crisis of our environment,
the shootings, the feeling
of safety all jeopardized,
very big issues that
could really sink anyone.
The key here is how do
I respond and react?
That's how I'm taught in
recovery is now what's going on?
How do I react to what's going on?
And I do it by then talking about,
like you said, the hopeful things.
My four-year-old came
into my bed this morning,
and put his hand on my face,
like, that his affect
that he's so affectionate.
I lay there and was just soak that in
'cause it was like one of
the best parts of the day.
Yesterday I got to give him a mop-up bin
where you put all the water to do the mop.
I fit him in, he fit
into this bin of water,
and had a bubble bath.
And it was just I just loved.
Myself, like, I can see
that as a joy today,
and that relieves the
tension and the stress
of having to kind of ruminate
about all that's going on
in the world like every other American,
anyone else in the world I could
easily get carried away by.
- Wow, such a helpful perspective,
and great stories, too.
And as someone who is
also a neuroscientist,
I'm resonating with what
you're saying about the brain,
and thinking about all
those aspects as well.
And even topics that we've talked about,
even just our interactions
with our family members,
and what that does to our brains,
and the oxytocin that gets released.
And as you said, that just
helps us kind of move through,
and even as you're so proactive
about that mindset shift,
and really using that to move
through, so I appreciate that.
- Well, you know, Dr. Addy,
I love the neuroscience because I read
the "Dopamine Nation" by one
of your colleagues in Stanford
talk about how we're
constantly in our society
trying to push all the buttons
to flood our brains with dopamine.
And another way of saying
is we're engaged in kind of
addictive behaviors to try to
feed our feeling of anxiety,
to medicate that.
And you can do it beyond
just drugs and alcohol.
I mean, I'm in recovery
from active use of drugs and alcohol,
but I can feel those
dopamine receptors by, quote,
acting out in any number
of the seven deadly sins
'cause they give me a short burst,
but in that neuroscience story,
it shows me that I have a hangover,
whether I have drank too
much, or drugged too much,
or act out too much on any
number of the dopamine stimuli
that I could try to use to self-medicate.
Anyway, what I'm saying to your audience
is that understanding the neuroscience
really helps me think about this
more than just as a philosophical issue.
It explains why I wanna be in recovery
because that actually
makes me feel better.
I love you're mentioning the oxytocin
because I hold onto my babies,
and I get all close up.
I got five kids because
I know that it's like,
it's not medicating for
me just to give them hugs.
And I know for them it's key
because I know their
brains are developing,
and I want them to be solid foundations.
And it's not enough for me
just to not drink and drug
because I know that
makes them feel better,
but because I wanna reinforce
kind of positive feelings
of agency for them and awareness, so.
- That's great.
I love hearing you share about
that and just all the things
that that does to our reward centers
as we talk about as well.
And even as you were talking,
as I do addiction
research and we find that,
even if we're doing
things in rats or mice,
if they play and have that time,
it makes it much less likely
they'll take more substance,
or take to excess,
so it's wonderful to just
hear you elaborate on that,
and give these stories as well.
And just to hear the
passion in your voice,
because I can really see how
that passion has infiltrated
into all of the work that you've done
on so many different fronts,
especially with the Kennedy Forum,
and so many other things.
So as you've been
highlighting those pieces,
I wonder if you'd also just
share a little bit about
how the Kennedy Forum came about.
What was the journey that
brought you to this place?
And then at some point we'll
delve into some of the work
that you do within the
organization as well.
- Well, I got elected as
a state legislator at 21
in Rhode Island I was the youngest member.
I was elected at 26 to Congress
as the youngest member of Congress,
and then chosen to be in leadership at 31.
I can guarantee you, Dr.
Addy, none of it had to do
with my last name being
Kennedy whatsoever.
It was all my good looks and
personality that got me so far.
- Of course, of course.
- So there's something very
powerful about my uncle,
President Kennedy's new frontier,
the message of hopefulness that he gave
when he embarked on the Peace Corps.
When he set a vision for going to the moon
in under 10 years,
which was thought of as being
way over his skis at the time.
And it's just aspirational
aspects of his leadership.
And that still resonates to people today
who are looking for narrative and context.
So I've woven his work on
civil rights, for example,
as the first president to speak about that
as a moral issue when he said,
who amongst us would trade
the color of their skin,
and then be content with those
who counsel patience and delay?
In other words, the Golden Rule.
How would you like to be treated?
Think about what it's like to
have different colored skin,
and be living in this country
where you're still feeling
as though the country doesn't accept you.
And the racialization of many
institutions in this country
that still is so demoralizing
to our friends and neighbors
who have different colored skin
who don't feel fully accepted in America.
Anyway, my point is,
is that these notions are very helpful
when I'm advocating for mental health.
And, ironically, my family
was very stigmatizing
on mental illness.
They were real visionaries and leaders,
but President Kennedy signed
the first Community Mental Health Act.
He grew up in a family
where no one spoke about
his sister's intellectual disability.
In fact, after my grandfather
chose to have a lobotomy for her,
and that was clearly unsuccessful,
and she was kind of put out
in a monastery in Wisconsin,
never to be seen or heard of again.
- Wow.
- Right?
That shame was so palpable
in my father's life.
And then, thankfully, my Aunt Eunice,
finally got the approval from her brother
to speak about it openly after
he was elected president.
And then from that came
the Special Olympics,
which is now in over 190
countries around the world,
and transforming the view
towards people with
intellectual disabilities,
but my point is that the silence and shame
that accompanied that terrible situation
with my Aunt Rosemary,
which by the way, was also
fueled by a psychiatric illness.
Many believed that she had
a kind of form of bipolar,
which coupled with her
intellectual disability
led her to outbursts
that made my grandparents
very uncomfortable,
which is what led to the lobotomy.
It's about talking about this in a way
that isn't stigmatizing.
And when I did mental
health and addiction,
that was very shameful in my family.
My mother suffered from profound
alcoholism and depression,
my father self-medicated.
He was traumatized
by his brother's assassinations
with murders, I mean,
but it was still that way,
and my father is a very
forward thinking guy,
but it was hard for him to get past
his generation's view of
mental health and addiction
as a character flaw as
opposed to a chemistry issue.
And I found that in the
course of my advocating,
I was trying to break the shackles
of living in that silence
and the imprisonment,
because not only did I
suffer from these illnesses,
as I said, my whole family did,
and there was something
I knew I had to do.
And by the way, I didn't
choose to do this.
The guy that I was in drug rehab with
sold his story of being in drug rehab
to the "National Inquirer" which outed me,
and, Dr. Addy, that ended
up being the best thing
that ever happened to me in
my life because instead of,
like, making this a
closely guarded secret,
when I got to Washington
I had already been outed.
So I could put my name
first on a bill that said
mental health ought to be treated the same
because unlike my colleagues
who are much more senior than me,
who could have been the
sponsors of that bill,
none of them wanted to answer
why they were a sponsor
of the bill that had both the words,
mental and addiction in the title,
'cause, of course, press
would naturally ask,
well, have you had any of
these issues in your life?
No one else wanted to answer them,
but because I was a Kennedy,
I was exposed early.
I hated it at the time,
but it ended up being
one of the best things
that ever happened to me.
- Wow, that's amazing to hear
the backstory for that too,
'cause even as you were talking,
'cause as you talked about the stigma
kind of being pervasive,
what it was that really
helped you push through that,
to say that there needs to be a shift,
and it sounds like there was some,
I don't know if serendipity
is the right word,
but not that you wouldn't have wanted to,
but that there was a situation
that allowed you to step into that.
And so I really applaud
you for making that shift.
And as you alluded to it's not that others
wouldn't have been
navigating that as well.
I mean, if we think about
our current statistics,
one in five who are living
currently with a mental illness.
So when we think about people
in government and politics,
that includes all of us.
So for you to really be
able to take that step.
and move it forward, I
think is so important.
Would you say you've seen
shifts in the perspective
amongst when you are in Congress,
amongst your colleagues
for moving that forward?
Because reading through
kind of the process of it,
and I'm sure that there was pushback
with that along the way as well.
So what was that process like,
and what have you seen shift over time?
- So because these are chronic illnesses,
just because I went to treatment at 17
didn't mean I was done.
I constantly grappled with this,
and, of course, I still
tried to keep it secret
because, of course, I assumed
even as the champion of parity
that I was supposed to be better, right?
I waws supposed to be okay.
And, of course, our health care system
never treated my illness
the way it does my asthma,
which is a chronic illness
and needs constant attention.
It just is a kind of acute
episodic treatment system, right?
That doesn't reimburse for
the chronic care nature
of these illnesses.
So that's a long way of
saying when I got a DWI,
because my illness still
hadn't been succeeded
in terms of its treatment
because these are chronic illnesses.
It was very shameful
when I went to treatment,
and it looked as though I was
gonna have to leave Congress.
I got a lot of letters
from colleagues telling me
that they were pulling for me,
which really folks that I
had never talked to before
when I was serving with them.
When I got back from treatment,
I went and visited many
of them to thank them.
And it was the first time I'd
ever had them tell me about
their own challenges.
And then I realized I
was in a unique place
because I was the only one
who had mental illness,
and addiction tattooed to his forehead
because I was the only one
of their colleagues that they knew,
when, in fact, now I had
the opposite benefit.
I had the eyes on the fact
that so many of my colleagues
had similar challenges in their own lives,
and in their family's lives
that none of the other
ones of them knew about,
but I had that secret perspective,
which I kept secret
'cause they asked me to,
but I met a lot of my colleagues.
Some of them who told me
very harrowing stories
about their own family's
mental illness and addiction
voted against
our Mental Health Parity
and Addiction Equity Act.
And I never outed them
or challenged them on it.
I did talk to them later on.
I said, how could you have
voted a no on that bill?
I thought you told me about
suicide in your family,
your daughter's eating
disorder, and so forth.
And they said, "Well,
Patrick, I don't come from
the same part of the
country you come from.
I come from the buckle of the Bible Belt.
Your constituents may be
all right reelecting you,
but I can't be sure mine would
reelect me if they knew."
And then they said something
even more powerful.
They said, "Frankly,
when I think about it,
if my child ever felt
that they were exposed, I can't
be sure what they would do."
Which, of course, the
end of that sentence is
I can't be sure whether they
wouldn't take their lives
because of the shame of
these illnesses, so, I mean,
that still shows you
that we made progress,
but there's still a lot of
caveats to that progress.
I also tell people,
like, we passed this law,
but it wasn't because everybody
woke up one day and said,
oh, wouldn't it be a good
thing that we cover the brain
like we would every
other organ of the body?
We passed this law because Chris Dodd
was a friend of my family's,
and our bill in the House was
the better of the two bills.
And I got Chris to pass
our Bill H.R. 1424,
by writing the whole Economic
Stabilization Act of 2008,
which is the Toxic Asset Relief Program.
In other words, the seven
to $800 billion bailout
of Jamie Dimon, and all the big bankers
that got us into this
mess in the first place
with our meltdown and
banking crisis in 2008.
That's how we got the Parity Bill passed.
So when George Bush signed the Parity Law,
he was really signing it
because it contained the
provisions to get our country
out of getting into another
financial great depression.
He wasn't signing it
because it mandated
coverage for depression, so.
The bottom line is up until COVID,
I haven't seen any
traction on mental health.
And since the time I
left Congress 'til today,
I have been pushing for the enforcement
of the Mental Health Parity
Law really to no avail.
All of the leading psychiatric hospitals,
and addiction treatment providers
really did not put their
shoulder behind this,
even though this was good for them.
And the reason was is because
they didn't wanna offend
the big payers because all
of them were so dependent
on the Uniteds, and Aetnas,
and Anthems, and Cignas.
And so it was interesting to me,
the very people who should
have been the most supportive
were kind of the most reticent.
And I thought to myself,
if we can't get the very providers
who benefit from this law
to support its implementation,
how am I gonna get
everyone else to support it
who feels stigmatized
'cause these illnesses?
So we're finally getting some attention,
but, Dr. Addy, it's
because corporate America
is nervous that the great resignation,
and the competition for talent means
that they better do
something on mental health
because these Gen Xers, and others,
these young workforce
is demanding no less.
And they know intuitively,
that if they don't
invest in mental health,
not only is it a cost on
their total health care costs
in their workforce,
but it's a cost to their
economic productivity,
but still today, Dr. Addy,
we have not wrapped our arms
around the full economic
implications of poor mental health,
and the full benefits of real
good integrated mental health
into the rest of physical health care.
And until we do, it's gonna
be still a push and pull
to get corporations to do
what's in their self-interest,
to get insurance companies to
get past this gatekeeper idea
that all they need to be doing
in this world is limiting
cost and access, which is
counterproductive in every way
as we know from the early data.
So it's still a long ways to go.
- Yeah, a long haul, and
I appreciate, I mean,
the way you've given us
just the full context.
I mean, even from the early work,
and the strategy involved in that.
and how you had to partner with others
to really move things
along in a certain way,
but it sounds like you're
also being very savvy
about the motivation behind that as well.
And you were kind of touching on this.
Do you feel like with everything
that's happened with COVID,
is there any shift whatsoever,
or any greater acknowledgement
that you think will help
move things forward,
or is it still just all
these aspects of resistance
that you've talked about
that are still kind of
the major roadblocks?
- So the 800 pound gorilla is that
we don't have enough workers
to meet the current crisis.
We're not gonna have near
the workers we need to meet
the future mental health crisis.
We've got a tsunami.
The racial pandemic, the COVID pandemic,
the economic dislocation,
moving into more
technology-based economies,
the dislocation of workers,
the global implications,
Ukraine, the virus, the environment.
I mean, it's just no shortage
and we're really not using,
as I said earlier our prefrontal cortex.
We're really acting out
of our mammalian brain.
Our amygdala is in full flight.
I really think we need
neuro-literacy in this country.
In other words, I think a generation ago,
corporate America pushed STEM education.
They didn't think we
had enough scientists,
technologists, mathematicians.
China was eating our lunch.
The rest of the world was advancing.
So corporate America said,
oh, we gotta teach this in our schools.
And that's where we ended up shifting
our educational paradigm.
We're gonna need to do the
same on neuro-literacy.
And the reason I'm saying
it is if we don't have
the next generation of
workers able to manage,
and cope with stress,
we're not gonna have a
productive workforce.
And I think this existential
crisis in corporate America
with the great resignation,
I think it's got them thinking,
oh my God, like, what are we gonna do?
Like this whole new generation,
they're not subscribing
to the old traditional paradigm of work,
and what is it gonna mean
to have them work for us?
How are we gonna make sure
they're optimal in their
capacity and we retain them?
I just think that it's gonna now require
that they really go back and think,
how are we producing people in this world
in a way where they can
be much more productive?
And it's basically
about a prevention model
because if we don't have that,
then stress as you know is
the environmental factor
that can tip off the
genetic predisposition
to all array of mental illnesses,
and addictions particularly.
So the key is to interrupt
that stress where possible
through tools that people can use
so that their predisposition,
if they have a greater
vulnerability to depression,
and anxiety, or an eating
disorder, or alcoholism,
that they can acknowledge that,
and then intervene and do these things
that we're just talking about,
go outside, connect with family,
understand the value of
interpersonal relationships
to their own mental health, so, yeah.
I think there's a lot to
wrap our arms around here.
- Yeah, well, so many important pieces
of what you've pulled out too as well.
I mean, as you acknowledged
just the workforce shortage,
but then also just the
need for the workforce
to be infiltrated in a sense.
And obviously that can be a challenge
when there aren't enough,
but I'm thinking in terms of
clinicians and researchers,
and just being out in the community,
and helping with this literacy,
as it were so to speak.
I mean, all the just different things
that you've highlighted of
all the needs that are there,
that were things really
need to kind of push,
and move forward.
So going back to something we mentioned
at the top of the episode, too,
even just thinking about hope
in the midst of everything,
because you've obviously had some things
that have been put into place
that aren't necessarily being implicated
as much as they should,
but at the same time you're continuing
to move things forward
even in the midst of that.
So I'm thinking about all
the different initiatives
that you've been involved in.
I'm thinking about One Mind.
I'm thinking about
the Kennedy Satcher Center
for Mental Health Equity
at the Morehouse School of Medicine,
which seemed like it was
pioneering in many ways,
speaking about and moving
forward in those aspects.
I'm thinking about the work
that you've been involved in,
and all that's going on with the Wit,
and the United Behavioral
Health case as well.
I'm wondering even in the
midst of the challenges,
how do you see hope in the midst
of what you're trying to do
in some of these efforts?
Because I've also heard
you say things like,
and you've alluded to that here,
that we need to get to a new normal.
How do you balance those two?
This is a little bit
of a personal question,
but also a little bit of
a programmatic question
in terms of how you
just go about this work
on a day to day basis with
all that needs to be done?
- Well, I get on my knees in the morning.
I try to humble myself and think about
what my greatest purpose and utility is.
And I know as I mentioned earlier,
I may not have had the smartest
best grade point average or the best this.
I've been blessed with
this family narrative
that I think is very conducive
to pulling these different
strings together,
and creating a narrative.
I think we've missed the narrative in this
because we have addiction over here,
and mental illness over here,
and then people with
mental wellness issues
aren't seeing themselves in either bucket.
We just don't have this holistic picture
that this is good for everybody.
The Green Berets have more mental health
than any other branch of the service.
And how do I know that?
Because John F. Kennedy
awarded the wearing of the green beret,
and I went and rededicated
the Fort Bragg Special Warfare School
named for John F. Kennedy.
And it was at that, that
General Hugh Shelton,
first chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff,
came up to me and said,
"Congressman, we have more mental health
for our Green Berets than any
other branch of the service."
And I knew he had seen my CV.
So I thought to myself, well,
he's just being political.
So I said, "General,
listen, these Green Berets,
they don't need mental health.
They jump out of airplanes,
and they hit the water,
and they swim under water for
five miles without breathing.
And then they hit the beach
and they speak six languages,
and they take out their target,
and they're reading to
their kids by dinnertime.
They don't need mental health."
And General Shelton said,
"Congressman, you don't understand."
And I was like, taken back, like, "What?"
And he said,
"We look at mental health
as a force multiplier."
And I thought to myself, brilliant.
I had never heard that before.
I just thought of mental
health as being about deficits.
I never thought about mental health
being the glass was half full.
Like you mean people who are
strong also need mental health?
And so I asked him about it.
He said, "Yeah, we need
our special operators
to work at their optimal full capacity."
And so I was like, that makes sense.
And my point is,
is that that and then my
family history of civil rights
got me this perspective,
like, when David Satcher
who I'd worked with,
when he was surgeon general,
was the first surgeon general
to do a mental health report,
called on me after I left Congress said,
"Do you wanna be part of
Morehouse School of Medicine?"
I mean, first I had to say yes,
'cause David Satcher was
in jail with Dr. King,
amongst a lot of young student
protestors at the time.
And to my view of growing up
they're part of our founding fathers.
They're the ones who laid the groundwork
for a modern-day America
where we passed the Civil
Rights Act, Voting Rights Act,
Fair Housing Act, Fair Employment,
all of which laid the ground
for progress in this country
for more Americans to be included
in the circle of opportunity,
as opposed to just being
an elite selective society
of just a few people
who had all the power.
So I said, "Yes."
That was 10 years before George Floyd.
I had no idea because
as most white Americans,
like, this thing that we
now saw with George Floyd
was happening every single day in America.
We didn't have it captured on video,
like it was so painfully captured
when George Floyd was killed.
And since then there's been
229 additional Black people
who have been killed
at the hands of police
since George Floyd.
I only know that
tragically to say because I've
been pulled into Morehouse
because of Dr. Satcher,
his relationship with my family,
my relationship with him,
to have a little bit broader perspective
than I would have otherwise.
And so I've been the
one who's learned about
what is vicarious trauma.
And when others tell me,
well, it's like seeing
your family members killed
routinely on television
in these photos because of
the color of their skin.
I have to go into my closet,
one of my friends said,
and take out all the hoodies in my closet
because I'm worried my
son is gonna be killed.
I'm saying to myself,
that's not my experience.
And then it dawns on me.
I have a moral obligation
to do everything I can
because if that were me,
I can't imagine the rage that I would have
if my family members
were constantly stopped
because they were suspected
of committing some type of crime,
because that's how we've racialized
our criminal justice system.
In any event, all of this, Dr. Addy,
is not out of my personal choice.
I have been born in an
environment that has worked on me,
and shaped me, which
I owe my existence to.
So when I think about
what do we need to do,
I think about trying to tie this together
as a modern-day medical
version of civil rights
because if you think about it,
mental health is separate and unequal.
And you think about people who
suffer from mental illness,
marginalized, and by the way,
like Black people shot inordinately
during emergency response,
vis-à-vis the general population.
And like with communities
of color also incarcerated
at much bigger numbers, right?
So you've got a lot of the same dynamics.
I never would've made those connections
had I not had my life experiences.
So when I say I get down on my knees,
I think about, well, what's my job?
It's to move with what I've been given.
And I've been given these
ways of looking at the world,
which help me in my view
advance this advocacy.
And by the way, I can advance it
because I got this family name.
I've got connections to
the corridors of power.
I can bring attention and I
don't have to feel diminished
because I also have
depression and anxiety.
I also have drug addiction.
Whereas, if I didn't have my last name,
maybe I wouldn't be so racing
to the door to be an advocate,
because let's be honest,
if people were just to
look at me as someone
who's in recovery from a
mental illness or addiction,
I could easily be dismissed.
So I feel like I have,
and by the way, I spend
a better part of my day,
helping my friends get connected to care
just in the microworld.
And also calling up my friends
from insurance companies
saying, you gotta cover this person.
It's your legal
obligation, and they do it,
but that's only because that's
what God has given me to do
with what I have been given in my life,
so finding purpose to me
is the way to find hope.
- Yeah, that's so powerful.
I mean, so much of what you said
resonates on so many levels.
I mean, obviously, it's sobering.
At the same time it's also refreshing.
And just hearing you talk through that,
just seeing all the
ways that you've really
just walked in community with others.
So that sounds like you're
not coming in saying
that you have all this
understanding already,
but you're partnering with
people who are trusted,
who are colleagues, who are friends,
even as you talked about Dr. Satcher,
and learning from people's experiences,
and just the way that you have been able
to incorporate that, and get
that level of understanding.
Granted, you didn't walk
through it yourself,
but just even as you related
to the rage that you would feel
if you were in that similar situation,
and I would say that's so important.
And even as you're sharing,
I'm still kind of just
processing and taking in all,
again, the passion that's there,
and the ways that you've
really been adamant about
putting it into practice,
and making sure that it's something
that can really help us shift and move
how we go about these things
on a day to day basis.
So just, again, gratitude for the ways
that you've acknowledged
the role that you have,
the opportunity that you have
in walking alongside others
to really make sure that
that comes to fruition
in so many different ways.
- Yeah, no, I mean, of course,
I've voted against
Defense of Marriage Act.
I was signing on everything,
civil rights, LGBTQ.
It was politically the
right thing to do, right?
As for my mindset.
I have a family member,
a daughter now who's
grappling with identity.
I could never have imagined
why the work that I did,
a decade two ago around this
issue could come home, right?
And I try to tell people,
even if you haven't had a mental illness,
or addiction in your family,
it's gonna come home to you at some point.
And what kind of world do
you want for your loved one?
Do you wanna have to wait six months
before you can see Dr. Addy?
Because that's right now what it takes
to get a really good psychiatric hearing,
and then what kind of therapeutic
are you gonna just be
shipped off to some kind of
one size fits all approach,
or is your loved one gonna
kind of get the curated
best evidence-based treatment
for their particular diagnosis?
So I was fortunate to get
great psychiatric care myself,
but I didn't get cognitive
behavioral therapy, Dr. Addy.
I'm very much interested in
getting CBT more adopted,
just generally, and incentivizing that,
and having kind of an Angie's List,
and a match.com set up so
that if I need to get care,
and if my daughter
has to get some skills
with eating disorders
that she's not going to someone
who's just good on depression and anxiety,
even though she has
depression and anxiety,
like, what is it that she'll need?
I want therapists that are
gonna be good for her, right?
And right now she'll be lucky
she gets anybody, right?
- Yeah.
- Not the least of which is someone
who can actually help her with
her particular challenges,
or someone who could
help me with mine, so.
We need to really ramp up
the delivery of evidence-based treatment,
in addition to doing
what the Parity Law says,
and that is pay for it.
Obviously, chicken and egg,
like, you gotta put a
lot more money in this,
but my hope is that when
we put more money in it,
we also demand kind of greater
outcomes at the same time,
because we have a double problem.
We have a problem of
accessing mental health,
but then we have another problem
of accessing quality mental
health, and we need to do both.
And that, by the way, takes payers,
and then, of course, it takes providers.
so it's not an either/or.
We need both of them
to be together in this.
- Yeah, it's so challenging
as you mentioned.
With some of the guests that
we've had on this program too,
we always talk about some of
the severe mental illnesses,
and things around suicide prevention,
as you are familiar with from your work,
just ways that we, actually,
in some ways need to rebuild the system,
but what can we do in the meantime
to really help things move forward?
And so, again, just know that
the work that you're doing
is so important in so many different ways.
And I'm wondering if you,
also, just talk a little
bit about the ongoing case,
and what really needs to
shift in ways that you think
that we can do that to have an impact,
even with the ongoing
case I alluded to earlier?
- Yeah, well, we need advocacy.
That's the big missing piece.
Like it's not as if I don't have
the whole matrix of
policies already enumerated
by every subcommittee in
the United States Congress,
like we've never had before.
I mean, this is not
just the purview of the Health Committee.
It's the purview of the Housing Committee,
the Labor Committee,
the Education Committee.
And my point is, is that it's
a comprehensive approach,
but what we need are we
need people to sign up.
Some people will be interested
in the supportive housing,
and the community model.
Others will be about the neuroscience,
and coming up with new
pharmaceutical interventions.
Others will be about expanding,
and getting rid of the IMD exclusion,
so people can get adequate
inpatient access to care,
expanding the telemental health.
The point is, is that we just
need an advocacy movement,
and we need to look at
what the Chamber of Commerce has done,
the League of Conservation
Voters, the AFL-CIO.
You could name your advocacy
group, they've got it all.
They've got what is the
uniform kind of agenda
that unites all of the affiliates
within organized labor?
Well, there's different types of unions,
but they all kind of agree,
well, we need kind of minimum
wage, fair labor, pensions.
We need decent health care.
You've got some standards, right?
And in environment it's
League of Conservation Voters.
Yeah, some of us are interested in air,
as osmotic water, land.
The whole idea is, yeah, but
we have a unified agenda.
These are the big issues.
Like we don't have that
in mental health yet.
Parity for years was kind
of the singular issue
that united the whole community,
whether you had addiction
or mental illness,
whether you were a
psychiatrist, or psychologist.
We need to bake this
so that everybody sees
their own advantage.
And we get, as I said,
the 28 million Americans
in long-term recovery
who were, quote, anonymous
out of these church basements,
and understanding that our founder Bill W.
testified in front of Congress,
that you can say you're a
person in long-term recovery
without having to acknowledge
the exact 12-step group
that you belong to,
and still maintain the
11th tradition of privacy
at the level of press,
newspaper, and radio.
So we just don't have a
sophistication in advocacy
that lends itself to
ramping these issues up.
Because my wife ran for
Congress this last cycle,
I could not get a list of
families impacted by this illness.
I couldn't get a list of
all the paraprofessionals
who treat these illnesses.
I couldn't get, I mean, I could
just keep going on and on.
Whereas, if I wanted to
reach working families,
I had every single union mailing list.
I would make a phone call.
There would be an automatic rally.
If my wife went out to do canvasing,
she'd be accompanied with 50
other of her fellow teachers.
Like we need that in mental
health and addiction.
And if we don't get that, Dr. Addy,
we can have all these great policies,
but they're not gonna translate
because we don't put
the money behind them,
and we don't put the bodies behind them.
And that's what we need the most.
- Yeah, just to change
all the way around from,
like you said, to making
sure that it's, I mean,
I'm thinking back to what you shared about
the Green Berets, too, it seemed like
it was baked into every
aspect of what they did.
And that was really where it
started and where it ended,
and how it just wrapped around.
So as much as we need to do that
on all these different components,
as you mentioned on all these
different subcommittees,
on all these different topics,
so important in so many ways.
I'm glad you brought your wife up as well.
Also, thinking about her role
previously as an educator,
and how important that
component is to even
as you were talking about some of the CBT,
I have some clinical
psychology colleagues,
who've talked about how they
love to see some of those
principles integrated into
the schools from day one,
so that people would have these skills
being taught within that system,
and have these skills to approach things.
So even as you mentioned, these are not,
oh, you only need these,
if you're starting to
navigate a mental illness,
but these are life skills,
mental wellness that we
should be incorporating.
So I'm wondering, though,
in the work that you all have done,
even the work that your wife has done,
how has that perspective
in terms of thinking about education,
and some of the challenges
around mental health,
and what needs to happen there,
how has that perspective
also impacted the work
that you've been doing?
- Well, if you think about it,
you got all these point
source solutions for obesity,
or sleep, or what have you.
We basically need a learning
management system for life
where we kind of like the internet model,
we understand how the whole thing works.
We know how to do Google,
and we know how to do,
but we need to have,
now some of us may have how do
we overcome these delusions?
And, frankly, people
with psychotic disorders,
there is cognitive
behavioral therapy on how to,
and there's even with suicide ideation.
It's not just simply a
matter of depression.
And I know John Krystal and others at Yale
have been really formative in this.
It's about a particular
type of impulse control
that you can actually do
cognitive behavioral therapy around,
and actually reduce the
suicide rate in this country.
And yet we don't use that,
especially when we have
people come get admitted
in ERs for suicide ideation,
we don't immediately say, hey, by the way,
there's this program where
you can dramatically reduce
the likelihood of you ever
dying by your own hand,
because now you will
have the tools necessary
when you feel that
desperation to not act on it.
And if you could get the results in cancer
that you can get in mental health
by adopting these evidence-based,
I mean, it'd be a no-brainer.
Plus, we'd be paid for it, Dr. Addy.
We have greater therapeutic interventions
that could make a bigger
survival difference
than all of these other medical services
that get reimbursed oodles
of dollars to pay for those,
and only move the disease
burden on the margins, right?
Compared to what would
happen in this space.
So I would say that
I really believe we need to understand
kind of at a basic level
what's the handbook in life?
How do we understand
our brain how it works?
How do we maximize our own challenges?
By the way,
that could apply to personal
relationships for some.
It could apply to drugs
and alcohol for others.
It could apply to workplace issues.
It's the mechanisms that are the same,
no matter what your choice
of what's your bedevilments, right?
And that's why the 12-step program
generally is worked across gambling,
and narcotics, and alcoholism,
and obesity, and all,
because the principles
are what are universal.
We need to embed that kind of principles
in a learning management system
that allows you to customize, if you will,
those principles for you in your own life.
So you learn how to break
that default thinking
as it applies to you, like
everyone's always after me,
or they're all trying to get me,
or I'm full of resentment.
Well, let's think about
how to dismantle that
because it's taking me offline
from being able to achieve
what I wanna achieve.
Americans love looking
better, feeling better.
Why not make this the thing that we want,
because if it's happiness
we're all for, right?
Fulfillment, contentment,
the best way to sell that
is to make that sort of
uniquely American consumerism apply to
how do I become a better consumer
for my own mental health?
So that's how I would think about it.
Of course, in education,
you've got that universal
public health approach.
So you're not trying to
play catch up down the line
when I'm in my 20s trying to
get recovered from addiction.
If I had earlier on been
equipped to be more aware,
I wouldn't let myself
constantly be kind of
deluded into thinking that
I still have got this.
Like, I could still manage my life,
which is what is the great unifying factor
of all people with
addiction, and mental illness
is that they think they're
not as bad as they really are.
It's that denial that we talk about,
but education's where we
could lay the foundation
for a really strong
future on mental health.
- Yeah, I wholeheartedly agree.
And as much as we can
set those foundations,
and put those things in place
and more that people like you,
and, hopefully, people like
me and others are partnering
to really make sure that
that really becomes embedded
in our education, our
framework, and our mentality.
And I'm grateful that some has
started to speak up about it,
but, again, there's so much
more that we have to do
around that front as well,
but it's so important
as you've enumerated.
And, again, just thinking about
even what you're doing with
some of the initiatives,
even like One Mind, and making sure
that there's opportunities
for the research to be done,
but also for people to be able to go out,
and to talk about that research,
and make sure that it's embedded
in everything that we do.
- I love the basic science in One Mind,
which is basically if you take
neurodegenerative disorders,
which are such a big challenge,
Parkinson's, Alzheimer's, and the like,
and you look at all the
affective disorders,
depression, anxiety,
addiction, and the like,
you would think, though,
well, if you study the
signature wounds of war,
traumatic brain injury,
and post-traumatic stress,
which you could get the
defense establishment,
by the way, define as a
national security issue,
which would then generate the
kind of federal investment
that you wouldn't be able to
get if you just defined it
as a kind of a medical issue, right?
You could get the world
behind these global datasets
that allow us to track
various interventions
'cause the brain is the most
complex organ in the body.
In order to decode it,
you need data on the size
that you've never seen before.
Ironically, back to this narrative piece,
JFK did the race to space.
That's when we needed super computers.
That's when we first started it.
Today, it's the race to inner space.
That is the big new frontier, right?
It's discovering the galaxy
of neurons in our brain,
and understanding
therapeutic interventions
that can save someone with ALS
to someone with debilitating OCD.
And, by the way, if you're
studying Parkinson's,
you have to understand
the dopamine response.
So you have to understand depression.
Who would imagine a
neurodegenerative illness
could also be a big point of interest
for people with affective disorders.
In other words, we're
all in this together.
And I just think that
the space station concept
where the world sees its
kind of combined interest
would be a great kind of,
because for us to be saved in America,
we need to get the Chinese
online with data as far as brain.
And we need the Australians,
and the Europeans,
and Latin Americans.
- Worldwide.
- I mean, we really need to
be global in our approach,
and we have the super computing
capacity like never before.
So we could really start
to understand this,
and get real solutions,
but we need a narrative.
And that's what we've been missing.
- Yeah, fully agree.
A narrative and the
community working together,
which is so important.
Again, something that I've
definitely seen in your work
on so many different levels as well.
And I'll say this podcast
itself is also about community.
One thing that we're trying to do, also,
is just trying to actually
incorporate input,
and feedback from the listeners as well.
So I want to pivot slightly,
and just also talk about
the new hotline the 988,
or forthcoming hotline
that's being made available.
One of our listeners had
had a question about that.
If you'd be willing to
just kind of talk about
your perspectives on that,
and what you see as the improvements,
or what that all will
mean for us as a country
trying to move forward on so
many of these important topics?
- Well, as you know our
criminal justice system
has been the default for a
lack of a mental health system,
and addiction treatment system.
So we end up incarcerating people
because we don't give
them the interventions
for their mental illness or addiction.
And as you know we incarcerate
a greater percentage of our population
than any other free industrialized
nation in the world.
So the indictment is actually
on our justice system
that it's not working,
it's not keeping us safe.
There is 75% recidivism from
state prison within five years,
50% within two years.
A majority of violent crimes
are committed by people
who've already been in prison.
Like, we should just look
at this thing and think of,
well, where do we want incarceration?
We want incarceration to protect us,
but outside of that, what do we want?
We wanna be making sure
that we treat people with mental illness.
We treat people with addiction.
In the 988 we're in the first opportunity
to really seek fundamental
reform in this paradigm
because instead of the
police officers showing up,
which as I mentioned earlier,
if you have a mental illness,
or you're a person of color,
you're more likely to be shot,
and have a much, obviously, poor response.
Let's think about how this 988
you could have in communities of color,
someone show up that
looks like the community
they're coming from.
You could have someone show up
who's not only someone
looks like the community,
but knows the situations
in terms of if it's a
person with mental illness,
knows how to deescalate.
And provide the right
intervention so that, one,
they don't get a criminal record,
and, therefore, they're able to recover
because it's easier to recover
if you can still get a job,
'cause you don't have this conviction
sitting over your head.
Wouldn't it be great to get
pre-adjudication in all of that?
And by the way, some of
these service courts,
like mental health courts,
drug courts, and the like,
are already showing the value of this.
In Rhode Island, I was
really proud to be part of
expanding the Veterans Court.
So in the wake of Iraq and Afghanistan,
we had the second highest percentage
of our Guard and Reserve war
police units, military police.
And they all came from Rhode Island's
municipal police academies
and organizations.
And what happened was
when they came back from
Iraq and Afghanistan,
they found themselves
showing up at incidences
where they were arresting
the very fellow officers
they had just served in Afghanistan with,
and in Iraq with who were suffering from
the untreated impact of
post-traumatic stress.
And so, of course, it was
bothering them this was happening.
And why should we be locking
up one of our freedom fighters,
one of our Veterans,
because we didn't adequately
take care of their,
quote, invisible wounds of war,
but, frankly, as you
know our response to the,
quote, invisible wounds of war
has been invisible in many respects.
We've tried to ramp up in the years past,
but we've been playing catch up
with 22 Veterans dying each
day at their own hands.
So my point is,
is that we need a different
emergency response.
And if we have a different response,
we'd get different outcomes down the line.
So why not try to train that up?
Now to do this,
you have to build out a
whole continuum of care,
which as I mentioned earlier,
we've so underfunded mental
health all these years,
we don't have an infrastructure
to meet this need.
988, in my view, Dr. Addy,
is gonna show the pitfalls
of our current system
as being inadequate because
when we stand this up,
everyone expects the
number of crisis calls
to minimally quadruple
just grow exponentially.
And we don't even have the capacity
to meet our current needs,
let alone inviting people
to use a three digit number,
and supposed to 911
to call for a mental
health crisis response.
And I just think the
thing's gonna fall down,
and implode on itself.
And then, hopefully, that
will spur us into action.
And we'll say, oh my God,
we were a little premature on this,
or maybe we didn't get ourselves
organized for it enough.
And we'll do what we need
to do to follow that up, so.
988, it's a big deal.
Honestly, there's very
little understanding of it
amongst the local, county,
municipal level officials
that are gonna be necessary
to put this into effect.
And so if they don't understand
it, and if by the way,
there's no kind of really
good technical assistance,
and how-to then what kind of system?
Because, by the way, it's gonna
change from locale to locale
because some systems are
gonna have really good
kind of maybe urgent care,
or really good the right number of people
to answer the phone,
but what about the people to
show up to help that person
are there enough of those people?
And what about the places to go?
So if you got a person answering the call,
then you need someone to show up,
then you need a place to go.
Like, we need, like, the whole continuum.
And different places in the country
have different aspects of that continuum.
It's gonna be a while
before we do this right,
but I'm glad at least that
we're moving down this road.
And my view, this is the
single biggest policy
paradigm shift in mental health
that we've seen since the Parity Law,
in terms of its implications
on the whole system.
- Yeah, that's saying a
lot, that's saying a lot,
but as you mentioned,
I think it's the healthy perspective, too,
just to see where things are moving,
but knowing that it will
also likely open up things
that also still need to be done.
And so I appreciate you
sharing that full perspective.
As you've been talking,
as we've been going through this episode,
I think this is also one of
those episodes where, hopefully,
it will facilitate and encourage people
to actually look into things,
and actually do some homework
around some of these topics, too.
I mean, so much of what
you share is really about
just education across the board,
and how we think about these topics,
and the work that you've
been doing as well.
So I hope that people will
feel inspired by the journey
that you've been on and what
you've been doing so far,
but also inspired to dig in themselves,
and to also look for ways
to educate themselves,
educate their community members,
and to tap into some of
these programs as well,
but as we wrap up any closing thoughts
that you want to leave our listeners with?
I mean, there's so many highlights,
and so many important things
that you've pulled out
in the conversation,
but anything that you really
wanna leave folks with?
- I'd say with COVID we got
real time data on everyone today
that got COVID their comorbidities,
and we've got a public health response.
Our data on suicide, our data
on overdose is two years old,
and it's messy data,
meaning it doesn't give
us the information we need
to make good policy decisions.
We need to systematically
really understand
what data we need to track
to get the right public health response,
and also to align the financial incentives
in our private sector
system to pay for the value
that comes from, for example,
paying for supportive housing,
vis-à-vis inpatient
psychiatric care, right?
We really need to understand
the social determinants of health
as it impacts mental health,
along with the impact of good
therapy, and good medicine,
and all of these other
things, and good providers.
So I would just encourage
people to lean in on this.
This to me is the big,
we've got a lot of big issues to solve,
but if we don't solve
the mental health piece,
we're not gonna get around
the toxicity of our political culture.
We're not gonna be able
to think straight about
how to solve some of these
environmental challenges
because of us ignoring the global warming.
We're not gonna be able to
deal with all of these issues
of racial pandemic and public
health pandemic of COVID,
if we don't really get to be stronger
in our understanding
ourselves, and how we relate,
and how we communicate,
and how our brains work.
So a lot to do.
I'm thrilled to be on your podcast,
and that you've got listeners
that are interested in this.
And, please, I know
we'll put in the links,
some of the work that we're doing
in case anyone's interested
in being part of it.
- Of course.
Well, Congressman Kennedy,
thank you so much for your time
for all the things that you shared.
I know me, personally,
I'm gonna go back, and re-listen to this
'cause there's so many important gems
that you dropped throughout this episode,
and just, again,
I appreciate the way you
put things in full context,
both in terms of things
that have been put in place,
but then also the work
that needs to be done,
and where things have stalled.
I think, also,
speaking from a mental
health advocacy standpoint,
I think it's always important
to hold both of those together
as we try to move forward.
And I'm wrapping it up, again,
just thinking about the hope,
and just the importance of community,
even as you talked about
your time with your family,
and your kids, and I feel like, hopefully,
for you even in this conversation,
it's been very genitive in that sense,
so I think this is also
a representation of that
even on so many levels as
we try to partner together
in these efforts across our society.
So thank you, again, for taking
the time and for being here.
- Thanks, Nii, and I look
forward to meeting you in person.
- Yeah, that would be wonderful.
(soft music)